Đây đây, em đang làm nó đang hơi không kiểm soát được
Thì đề tài của em là em sẽ cố gắng sử dụng GAN trong
Là tên, tên tổng toán anh ạ?
À vâng, em có, em viết tiếng Anh, quên chưa đổi lại
Thì em dùng GAN để detect cái SQL, tấn công SQL
Đây là mục tiêu, bài toán thì hiện tại dữ liệu sẽ hầu hết là dữ liệu của người dùng rất bình thường
Đôi lúc mới có dữ liệu tấn công thì tỷ lệ sẽ rời từ 100 trên 1 đến 1.000 trên 1
Theo phương pháp bình thường thì mình sẽ chỉ đơn giản là lọc dữ liệu rồi chuyển nó thành vector
Có thể dùng MOT để kiểu định dạng lại thì lúc này mình sẽ dùng GAN bởi vì GAN nó có thể học
Còn cái thằng kia nó chỉ đơn giản nội sinh, nghĩa là mình đưa cho nó cái gì thì nó cũng chỉ thay đổi các string
Nó chỉ học nội sinh thôi nhưng nó không có khả năng sinh ra những cái dữ liệu mới để mình có thể học tiếp
Em mới đề xuất ra, thì đây là mô hình của em ạ
Thì là đầu tiên là em sẽ lấy dữ liệu, là lấy dữ liệu trên Kaggle và một số cái Datap
lấy thêm dữ liệu của các cái CVE, nghĩa là người ta ghi nhận những cái tấn công
dữ liệu thì em lấy thì em cũng mới chỉ lấy khoảng 30.000
bởi vì là dữ liệu tấn công thực tế
thì khi mà em làm thì em thấy là hầu hết là nó chỉ là noise
nghĩa là nó chỉ có khả năng tấn công
lúc mà em gõ thật thì khả năng tấn công thực tế của nó là không có
Nó khá là ít, này em mới nhận ra
Còn tiếp theo là em sẽ
Trong mô hình nó sẽ có 2 thành phần
Đầu tiên là thành phần Generate
Và thành phần Phytic
Thì em có thêm vào là
Trong này là sẽ có thêm
Trong phần này em sẽ có thêm
Cái Mutation
Nghĩa là em sẽ cho nó biết định nghĩa
về cách cho cả hai thằng
cái
cái này
là em cũng mới
tìm hiểu ạ
thì em đang hiểu ạ là em sẽ cho nó biết là
bây giờ SPM Jackson thì nó sẽ
phải có những cái điều kiện tối thiểu
là gì ạ, em cho cả hai thằng
nó học luôn ạ, còn nếu mà làm
như kiểu bình thường thì nó đang hơi loạn ạ
sau khi mà
sau khi mà critic thành công xong ạ
em sẽ có thêm một lớp để check nữa
thì nó sẽ gồm ba cái ạ
Đầu tiên là kiểm tra xem có phải là SQL không
Là cái lờ 1
Tiếp theo là sẽ kiểm tra xem là
Khả năng injection của nó
Nghĩa là xem là thực tế nó có khả năng tấn công không
Hiện tại là em mới chỉ
Cho quét qua bộ thư viện
OpenSource ở trên mạng
Còn cái số 3 là em sẽ quét xem là
Độ đa dạng
Xem là nó có thực sự đa dạng
Nó có thực sự hơn được
Thay được thằng SMODE không ạ
Thì trong tương lai
Thứ hai thì em sẽ thay thế cái thằng L2 bằng cách là em cho tấn công thực tế trên các tương lửa thông dụng
Và cái cuối cùng là các cái thước đo để xem là mô hình của em đạt những giá trị nào
Vậy đây là kết quả
Thì nếu như mà tỷ lệ mà rất rất cân bằng như kiểu 500 trên 1
Cái cuộc ngoài cùng thì là nó thì cái mô hình gan nó sẽ hơn được cái phương pháp cơ bản
là 42%
nhưng mà càng lên cao
thì nếu mà tỷ lệ càng thấp
thì thằng Mod nó sẽ
thắng được thằng GAN
thì tỷ lệ đây em chọn là 100
100 trên 1 ạ
em cho rằng tỷ lệ mất cân bằng đủ để mình có thể
dùng phương pháp GAN
thì đây thì hình bên phải
thì là em cũng
thử là chia ra là 4 trường hợp
nghĩa là trong tấn công SQL sẽ có
4 trường hợp thì 2 trường hợp
đầu tiên là Boolean và
Và error thì là cái này là dựa trên phản hồi của máy chủ.
Nghĩa là nó không thực sự tấn công.
Nó sẽ đợi xem phản hồi máy chủ là gì và từ đó họ sẽ mường tượng xem là hệ thống của mô hình là như nào.
Thì nên là hai cái đầu là nó sẽ không có đặc biệt bởi vì nó chỉ đơn giản là tấn công những cái mà mình đã biết rồi ạ.
Nhưng mà hai cái cuối cùng là sẽ...